several ways writers fail to ask for
help some people suffer from superhero
syndrome could be male or female they
don't want to ask anyone for help they
want to do it themselves they don't need
know I've got this I don't need help I
know you've said that it's crucial for
writers to reach out how that to me is
the key between working and not working
like you could write the greatest script
in the world if you don't have the
courage in the belief to send it out
there
nothing will happen so I think there's
actually a book what is it ask and
you'll receive or just a and I think the
the idea is if you don't ask you will
never know if you don't have a clear
goal in mind that you are taking actions
toward on a daily a weekly a monthly a
yearly basis then the goal is not going
to happen so I think by moving through
the fear and I think the fear is
well-founded if the writing isn't there
if the writing isn't in the strongest
place possible I do believe that when
writers are fearful of asking it's
because they know the writing is a
barrier and so I think it's really
trusting that the writing is there or at
least enough of the voice is coming
through to make an impact and trusting
and believing that so that you can take
the action with confidence knowing that
you're not going to embarrass yourself
and even and also knowing the biggest
thing about asking is the worst they can
say is no so what so what you move on
let's suppose a writer is sending out
their material right but other than that
are there any other things they should
be doing to ask for help whether it's
feedback whether it's taking classes
I'm definitely of the belief when I look
at my writers that have had the greatest
success it has been a combination of
learning and I am always trying to
master how I teach and how different
platforms have different outcomes so
whether it's a big event at a
screenwriting conference whether it is
an individual class whether it's a
10-week teleseminar or whether it's
one-on-one consult it's really
recognizing how do you learn in the
strongest way possible and I talk with
writers about that all the time I've had
my greatest success with writers who
take my 10-week teleseminar and then do
one among consults and the reason for
this is they get the story instruction
so that they understand how I see story
and how what I believe in the system
that I've developed that will take them
to the next level and then when they do
the one-on-one consult they have a very
strong knowledge of my terminology and
writers who've read my books and then do
the one online console then you have a
stronger opportunity to get the outcome
that you want so I think what any story
consultant that you're going to work
with I definitely believe do your
research see the videos that they
produce read the books that they've
written go to their classes know know
their philosophy and know if it aligns
with you and what you want how can you
tell if a writer is not growing command
a lot of the people that come to you
fairly self-aware or or maybe not maybe
they're really good at writing a story
but the self-awareness isn't there or
maybe I'm all no you're not wrong I
there definitely are writers that I work
with
where the growth isn't happening as
quickly as it could and I think that
that comes down to the emotional block
that comes down to they're not doing the
work they're hearing the notes they're
loosely taking the notes they're not
going beyond the note and they're not
open to really learn the process and
that really comes down to the writer and
why they're motivated and understanding
their own Y like that's another thing I
work with writers on is what is your Y
for wanting to be a working writer and
what is the worst that can happen if you
don't achieve the goal and how do you
utilize that as fuel so that you will
achieve a goal interesting so the worst
absolute thing they write it down and
they kind of work from that point on
mm-hmm what do you find is the most
common reason well I think you know I
certainly never forget like at the
beginning of my consulting probably
seven or eight years ago a writer came
to me and I understood and we have
worked on a few scripts together and he
was professor at a major college and he
had a wife and a child and he said I
need you to tell me the truth is this a
pipe dream should I be spending my time
on this or should I be doing something
else and my response to that was only
you can answer that question and the
fact that your aunt's asking it you have
to think about
and I believe that I can tell a writer
where they're at in the process I can
tell a writer out of all the scripts
I've read this is where you're at and
they can either utilize that to move
forward or they can fall victim to that
and that's what makes the difference
between a writer that succeeds and one
that doesn't the thing writers have to
understand more than anything else is
everything that happens to them
rejection wise is only going to happen
further in their career so the more they
adjust to bouncing off rejection and
using it to move forward instead of
falling victim to it the better their
chances of success like I look at I mean
I look at the right I'm always looking
at because I worked with countless
executive producers and in the thought
certainly could be oh now that they're
at this level and they have an overall
deal and they have a show that just got
huge ratings and they'll be happy and
what I found is it's this ongoing hunger
and thirst that will never truly be
fulfilled and it's accepting that and
it's utilizing that and it's it's
knowing that that's what drives the
writer like I look at writers in this
business constantly who will have great
careers and then completely disappear
and you won't hear from them for a long
long time in many years later they'll
create their own show and although okay
they were living life and now they have
more to say and I want to see what they
have to say
so I think it is knowing the life
process I've also had writers come to me
who will say Jen I can't deal with this
lifestyle because I'll work for a year
and a half and then I won't work for a
year and then I'll maybe work for a year
again
and then I won't work for two years like
what is this and all I can say to that
is you have to always be writing the
working writers biggest mistake is they
stop writing and when you stop writing
pager on staff for five years
so that when you're you're suddenly not
staffed anymore and you don't have three
new pilots to take out then you don't
have anything to show that you're what
has happened to your writing over that
five years that you've been on staff